hello YouTube chess lovers in my friends
this is grunge n here welcome to the
15th episode of dirty tricks after the
order P 4 P 5 Bishop to c4 and Knight to
f6 I propose here a very aggressive line
starting with the Moody 4 and after he
captures d4 I suggest a dangerous
Rousseau gambit starting with the move
Knight to f3 with this move white offers
a second point to the black and in my
last dirty chess trick video we have
gone through some of the reply of the
black wear black declined this cabbage
in this lecture we are going to
concentrate on blacks main reply that is
Knight captures e4 now first things
first whenever you open and capture the
second phone from inside you should feel
like this yes yes yes the simple reason
is it's ok there right is a material
down but white will have a tremendous
fun and attack where black is going to
sit very passively to defend his my
sleep on which is exactly we want there
are two good things which I like to
mention before we move on number one is
the piece layout of Russo gambit
accepted lines are pretty much fixed
that means you can do a heavy research
on this line and get a good result out
of it the number 2 is when I have gone
through the theory section of the Russo
gambit I was very shocked because the
theory is very old there are many good
nuances exist and if you open and rely
on this old theory then there is always
chance that you can surprise him and
finish him very very quickly
now the MU I'm going to recommend over
here is Queen captures d4
afterwards a black try to defend the
night with the move Queen to e7 then why
it has a very good reply that is castle
on the King side that means black has to
move the knight at this point
now the question is where knight should
move there are three places this Knight
can go amongst them Knight to f6 is the
main line but we should see what will
happen if you open in place other moves
for example the first move I want to
consider is Knight to d6 well after this
move I'm recommending that why should
castle on the kingside a black is
tempted to capture the active five
bishop that is Knight capture c4 then we
have the first trick on the table yup is
rook to even check only good way to
defend is Bishop to e7 but afterwards
Queen captures g7 attacking the rook and
after rook to f8 you spot it yep is
Bishop to at six boom so just a Lind
opening at least white will have
exchanged up advantage the same can be
said if you operand place Knight to c6
at this point the simple repetition is
you give this check we already look at
it what will happen if you operand plays
the move Bishop to e7 so the only other
moves to look out is Knight to e7 but
then white can simply drop his bishop
back to the b3 and black is incomplete
Zuke's way in one game
my opponent try the move Knight to f5 I
responded with the move Queen to defy
hitting the f7 so he dropped his Knight
back again to the d6 but this Knight
dance will not help the black because I
come with a very strong reply that is
Knight to g5 and black is finished right
there he tried the mood f6 but he missed
my next move Queen f7 check Knight takes
and Bishop to f7 checkmate so with this
analysis we can easily conclude that
Knight to d6 at this point is not a good
move let's look at another move that is
Knight to c5 well this is a very dubious
move and the easiest repetition is you
play the move Bishop to g5 hitting the
Queen
kindly note if Bishop to e7 then the
simplest is Queen to g7 and this
position is quite good for the white so
accordingly black has to play the move
f6 but after this move but will simply
drop his bishop back to the e3 and it's
very funny position for black not only
black cannot castle on the Kings side
but it has a stupid night on the c5 and
on top of everything white has this
tremendous leading development so with
this all analysis we can easily conclude
that at this point the best move for the
black is to play the move Knight to f6
now when your opponent plays the move
Knight to f6 there is one thing you
should always remember that you should
never castle on the Kings side you're
always going to castle on the Queen side
and attack black which in most of the
lines going to castle on the Kings side
here I should continue with the move
Bishop to g5 the main line goes with the
move Bishop to e7 white played light to
c3 and now there are three setups which
black has used in most of the case so
the number one set of is black plays the
move Castle combining with the move
Knight to c6 and the d6 the second set
of is black castle with the combining
the mood c6 and the D file and the third
and the very dangerous setup is black
King remain in the center with playing
the moves c6 and d5 so let's look at the
first set of wear white continue with
the move Knight to c6 hitting the Queen
the obvious move for the Queen over here
is Queen to h4 and after black castle on
the King side we should castle on the
Queen side and this is one of the very
ideal setup for Rosso gambit accepted
white pcs are very very aggressively
placed on the black King side and you
will see amazing 5x very very soon
obviously black we continue over here
with the move d6 so free up is under
bishop and now the old theory suggests
over here is to play the Mook to even
which I don't think is an accurate move
because it allows black to play the move
Bishop to f5
so my own personal recommendation over
here is you play immediate Bishop to d3
stopping Bishop to a5 line and not only
that there is a nasty trick looming that
what is threatening to play the move
Bishop captures night and then Queen
captures at 7:00 checkmate
so black has to parry that threat now
there are two is black and stop this the
number one is black plays the move at
six but this is just asking for it and
no price for the gas in fights next move
that is Bishop captures at six boom now
I read this position few times in my
games where my opponent try two
different moves in the first game my
opponent try the move Knight to d5 his
idea is to attacking the White Queen but
he completely missed my next reply that
is Bishop to g5 so that Knight is
hanging as well as there is a checkmate
three tone at sell in the second game my
opponent happily accept this bishop but
after Queen captures at six
not only White has enough compensation
but white lace at this point
threatening the move Knight to d5 and
then Queen to at seven so after a long
thinking my opponent diffused this
threat with the move Knight to e4 his
idea is to not only stopping the defy
but he wants to capture my bishop
no matter I continue with the move
Knight to g5 so pressurizing at seven
more my opponent captured this Bishop
but this allows my another piece comes
into the picture immediately with the
move rook to d3 so now the rook will
move across to the third rank and that
will deliver a deadly checkmate to the
black king with the desperate measure my
opponent try the move Bishop to a5
defending and the same time attacking I
responded with the move rook to g3 so
there is idea of discover check which my
opponent block it with the move Bishop
to g6 completely missings white next
reply once again I like you to pause
this video and find out amazing blow
which can completely finish up the black
okay I hope you find this move that is
Knight to e6 so there is a checkmate
threat and that Knight is [ __ ] Queen
in a row so that has to be taken but
after this we have a simple checkmate
sequence starting with the move Queen
captures Bishop came to h8 and Queen to
g7 as a check later so that was about at
6 now let's see what will happen if you
open plays the mood g6
well after g6 I'm recommending that you
should play the move rook h2 even and
now there's a dangerous threat of
captioning rook to e7 so for example if
a careless opponent plays moves such as
rope to it then you can simply snap up
that bishop and after Queen takes you
can capture this piece and if the Queen
goes to their fate then Knight to defy
is very strong move if the Queen goes
somewhere else then Quinn - at 6:00 and
bye-bye mr. King so you can see the
potential of this line it has a
tremendous attack with every single move
or they have to route to even the
obvious reply is to stop rook captures
c7 with the move Bishop to e6 but once
again this will not stop us for
attacking plaquing here I will continue
with the mood g4 so idea is to play the
move Bishop to a5 let's take a random
move for example from the black side
that is a Phi then the simplest is you
play Bishop f5 and now you destroy that
defender and then grab the e7 Bishop I
read this position in one rapid game
with a very high rated opponent and
after a long thinking he come out with
the move Knight captures g4 so his idea
is to stopping Bishop to a5 but he
missed what he means that he has played
the low so gambit accepted line and why
he's always going to surprise black and
in this case yep is rook captures east
six BAM after F kept his a six and Queen
captures g4 the game doesn't last long
my opponent continued with the move
Bishop captures GFI I continue with the
Moon Knight captures GFI and now he
played the move rook captures f2 which
is equal to the resignation because I
continue with the Queen check kindly
note if King to g7 then Queen to e3
nabbing the rook so my opponent played
the move King to h8 but after Knight to
f7 check rook takes and Quinn takes
white emerge with a clear piece
advantage okay let's have a look to the
second structure played by the black
that is castle on the Kings side and
after a white castle on the King side
black plays the move c6 so his idea is
to play the move defy as quickly as
possible well against this I am
recommending that you should continue
with the move rook to even and after the
move defy you should place the bishop on
a very nice diagonal that is d3 instead
of D Phi if your parent players are very
cheeky move that is at 6 then he will be
thrilled by White's next obvious move
Bishop captures at 6 after G captures
and Queen to e3 what is attacking to
sports and if black defend with the move
rook to e8 then he is in for the big big
surprise now folks question is on your
side what is the best move white played
at this position ok I hope you find this
move that is Bishop captures f7
boom amazing stuff black has to capture
this and after this we continue with the
move Knight to e5 check and after King
to g7 white simply play the move Queen
to g3 so black king is clearly naked and
on top of everything the King dance is
going to continue the game continues
with the move Knight to g4 I captured
the piece now my opponent play the move
Bishop to g5 but after the move f4 I
regain every single material which I
have sacrificed with a big big interest
so let me show you the rest of them
is very very quickly my opponent played
the move d6 attacking the Queen I played
Queen to g3 he responded with the move
Queen to f6
but after pawn captures Queen captures
Queen captures pawn captures and rook
captures d6 white emerge which not only
clear pawn advantage but a tremendous
leading development so that's why at six
is not a good move at this point the
main move is defy afterwards what we
play the move Bishop to d3 and now as
for the world theory black has to play
the move Bishop to e6 and complete his
speech development with the move Knight
to d7
well Bishop to e6 is not an accurate
move and the easiest repetition is you
play the move Queen to h4 creating a
similar threat that is Bishop captures
at 6 and Queen captures at 7 there are
three replies black and try but amongst
them the worst one is Knight B to d7
because here White has this surprise
that is Bishop captures at 7 boom cannae
note if King to a check then Bishop to
f4 is a very strong move and if black
captures this piece then after Bishop
captures a seven white will come out
with an exchange up so Knight B to d7 is
not at all a good move the second move
black and try over here is g6 but after
this move I propose that Y should
continue with the move Knight to d4
hitting the bishop and that Bishop
cannot move why let's say the bishop
moves then yep you got it of a familiar
trick that is rope captures and after
Queen captures we have Bishop to f6 and
bye-bye miss Queen so if Bishop cannot
move then any move for example let's say
rook to e8 then after Knight captures
pawn captures and rook captures not only
White has regained his all material but
White has a tremendous attack going on
the third and the final new blackened
tower here is at six well against this
you can do Bishop captures at six but
with the help of engine I found a very
strong move rook catches a six boom
Black has two choices but both are not
good number one is if H catches G Phi
then if I can get to this pawn with the
night so the idea is to capturing the
night and then deliver a checkmate on at
seven I lease this position in one of my
game where my opponent forcefully
captured this rook but in fact this is
not the best move so I give you as an
exercise there is a checkmate in six
guides you can pause the video and find
it by your own I am showing you right
now so the first move is Bishop check
King h8 Bishop to a5 discover chat King
to g8 Bishop to e6 check rook to f7
Bishop captures f7 King to f8 Queen
check Knight to g8 and Queen captures g8
as a checkmate okay what about F
captures c6 well against this we have
another super reply that is Bishop
captures at six boom well what's the big
idea the idea is very simple
then black cap to this piece then we
have this Queen check and after King to
h8 we have Queen to g6 and it's very
hard for black to defend this threat for
example in one game my opponent try the
move Queen to eh then I continue with
the Queen check and after King to g8
there is the move Knight to e5 which
more or less stamp the victory my
opponent continues with the move Queen
to h5 but this is a blunder move and the
simplest repetition is you kill this
check which more or less nap the Queen
because if King to h8 then Knight to g6
and in the game my opponent plays the
move Knight captures but then I simply
capture his queen
and black doesn't have enough
compensation for this Queen okay now the
third and the final set of black and try
over here is to play the MU c6 and defy
combining with completely avoiding
castle on the King side or maybe castle
long and this is probably the choice of
very high ranked players such as GM's
and super GM's now as overall so gambit
player the good news is three were
champions Lasker Steines and carpel has
been demolished with the help of this
gambit this is exactly I'm going to show
in this part I'm going to show two
amazing games in also gambit where two
world champions go down the line very
very quickly so the first game I'm going
to show you is between fen reach and
Stein ease we're at this point
Stannis responded with the move c6 and
after the mooncastle on the Queen side
he played the move defy well against
this I'm recommending that you should
continue with the move rook to even
completely pinning down that pawn
because if black foolishly captured this
Bishop then there comes Queen captures
da checkmate rather nice right so that's
not possible
now as for the world theory the old move
is Bishop to e6
so now black indeed threatening that
Bishop so we have to move the bishop to
the lowly diagonal that is Bishop to d3
and now if you're put in place move such
as castle or at six then we are going to
play the move Queen to h4 and that will
be a transposition of the lines which we
have already look at it so only
independent moves over here our Queen to
Fr and Knight to d7 now in this game we
are going to see the Stein is played the
move Queen to e5 which at first sight
looks very good move because it
pressurizing a two and the planning is
to quickly go for the move c5 now in the
game fiendish plays the nature looking
move that is king to be won but I found
a very good improvement in this line
that is you pair the move Bishop to fi
and this is completely refuted Queen to
e4 line
now the aim is to eliminate the bishop
and get the material back with a
tremendous attack and if black accept
the sacrifice that is Bishop captures Fi
then there comes Bishop captures f6 pawn
captures and we have a lovely move Queen
captures f6 attacking three pieces so
not only white game his material back
but black can hardly survive in this
sort of positions so this is a very good
improvement compared to the MU King to
be one but now the last scheme to be one
has his own venom so let's see what's
the idea of fent rich after King to be
when Stannis completed his piece
development with the move Knight B to d7
and while played the Moon Knight to e5
so idea is very simple and some lines
white wants to eliminate that night and
then quickly go for the move f4 f5 so
here a stand is decided to counter blow
with the move C Phi and we know where
this Queen belong yup it's Queen to h4
that's the spot we are always going to
put our cream now at 6 is not possible
because it's not attacking bishop so in
this game Stein is played the moonlight
captures ePHI and after rook captures
ePHI he simply castle on the Queen side
so this is a very safe of rose by world
champion and as a word you should know
exactly what you are going to do about
it now the approach by the offender is
very good he drop his Bishop back
immediately with the d2 so there is idea
of discovering attack to the black Queen
so Stan is dropped his queen back to the
c7 attacking the rook and now a superb
move by friend rich
he played the move Knight to B file
attacking the Queen one more time a
black played the MU Queen to b6 or
Knight to g4 then the game will be
continued on equal platforms but in this
game Stannis become very greedy and he
captured this rook which doesn't turn
out well now before I proceed I like you
to pause this video and find out an
amazing plan which more or less stem the
victory for the white okay I hope you
find this mu that is Bishop to
for attacking the Queen so the Queen has
the only place left that is Queen to h5
and probably Stein is thought that he is
completely winning in this position but
the matter of the fact is the reverse is
true and this is the only case where
world champion has been checkmated by
his lower ranked opponent so here
offenders continue with the moonlight
check and after King to d7 yup the
lovely move Bishop to b5 and it's a
checkmate whoa now the second game I
want to show you is between Timoshenko
and carpo played in the year 1967 where
instead of Stannis Queen - if I move
carpeau decided to play the Moon Knight
B to d7 but it's in fact one of the main
model line against this I'm recommending
that you should play over as usual Queen
move Queen to h4 and now there are four
different tries done by the black
amongst them c5 is only the critical
moon for example if black castle on the
kingside then this is a dubious move and
the simple repetition is Bishop captures
at 7 of a same old trick so that's not
possible if Queen to fi at this point
then the simplest repetition is you play
the move Knight to d4 and now your idea
is to play the move f4 f5 with a very
good attack if night to see if I wear
pretty much same story you play the move
Knight to d4 and go for therefore f5
move and this is the typical plan
especially in Queen to a5 night to c5
moves so let's consider the most
critical move which has been played by
the carpol that is C 5 it's a general
rule that whenever black plays the move
c5 in such a scenario then you always
come up with the move Knight to e5 so
idea is very simple you want to
eliminate that night at the right point
and the same time always looking for the
move f4 f5 tiny note if black Plains Rd
4 at this point then Knight to d7 is a
very strong move and the second option
black and try over here is to move c4
but against this I have
usually cooked a very nice move that is
bishop to a fire
well what's the idea that is very simple
we want to get rid of the black defender
on e6 and if black captures this piece
then there comes Knight captures Bishop
captures Bishop captures pawn captures
and the amazing blow Luke captures c7
boom no matter how black recapture for
example in one online game black
responded with the MU Queen captures a
seven white continues with the Moon
Knight to defy and after Queen to e2
white give this check which nab the
piece with a very good interest so I
think considering all this carpeau
played the Moon Knight captures ePHI and
after rook captures ePHI he responded
with the move d4 but it turns out that
d4 doesn't threaten anything because
white simply replied with the of a
typical plan
f4 and now to his hard
probably carpeau find out that he cannot
capture a piece the simplest reason is
after Bishop to b4 check black just
loses the Queen in order to make things
complicated he'd laid the Moon Knight to
d7 so attacking the rook no matter white
continue with the move Bishop to b5 so
pinning the Black Knight and after
Bishop captures and pawn captures
carpeaux made a decisive blunder that is
Quinn to c7 so his idea is to attacking
the rook but he clearly missed the
White's next move that is Bishop
captures Knight which more or less force
black to capture with the key because if
Queen captures then white has this very
strong move g6 if f6 then rook captures
Bishop and then another group coming on
the e-file the best move suggested by
the engine over here is at 6 but this
doesn't stop white attack because now
white can continue with the move G
captures f7 check King captures Queen fo
check King to g8 and the lovely move
root cap to c5 wait
not only Defour point is dropping but
that king is highly described the safe
piece so considering all those car
populate the move King captures and
funny enough is that night is hanging
for a long time but black cannot capture
that night the white continue with the
move Queen to d4 and one a lovely
decisive long game which I recommend you
guys to such in the database and go
through the game that's it folks I hope
with this wonderful analysis you can
confidently play the move Rosso gambit
accepted and have lots of fun feel free
to like subscribe and comment on my
video and we'll meet you in my next
dirty chess trick series until then good
bye and take care
you